welcome back to the rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of the
Guardians of the Galaxy holiday special
another Marvel Studios special
presentation a wholesome holiday story
that brings home the bacon hides in some
festive MCU Easter eggs and sets up some
big details regardings to the Galaxy Vol
3. so let's break it down shot by
Shopper everything you missed and thanks
to boxu for sponsoring this video more
on their tasty offerings later we again
see Marvel's special presentation
Fanfare with Michael chiquino's Bongo
music and graphic inspired by the 70s
CBS special presentation Fanfare but
then the Marvel Studios title has
replaced the flipping comic book pages
with specifically Christmasy marble ones
yes Santa does exist in the Marvel
Comics lore among these we see Hulk
Santa with Little Avengers is actually
art by salvat Natalina some Avengers
stockings there's a cat themed one a
Hulk themed one a Spider-Man one a shot
of Carol Danvers with Santa I think
that's in Captain Marvel Volume 8 number
11 and then a cover of The Sensational
She-Hulk where Santa is introduced as
detective Nick St Christopher snow
drifts over all this Marvel Studios
Fanfare and as always the interior of
the letters has been updated with new
Heroes She-Hulk has been added to the a
that's the moment she thunderclaps
Daredevil and episode 8. briefly in the
m and the a we see Gamora and Peter
quills side by side the long lost lovers
of the Guardians whom we hope will
reunite ever since the 2014 variant of
Gamora parted ways of the Guardians in
the final minutes of end game Kamala
Khan is still in the r but now they've
added shuri from Black Panther will kind
of forever to the V and then of course
some nice Christmas string lights all
around the logo now the music under this
is the pogue's 1987 fairy tale of New
York really the best Irish Drinking Song
Christmas Carol there is though careful
with this one the lyrics Do get pretty
effed up at one point it's from the
point of view of an Irishman in a New
York drunk tank singer Shane McGowan
recalling fights that he had with his ex
a woman whose Broadway dreams he crushed
her part sung by Christy mccole James
Gunn never picks songs randomly they're
always a diegetic compliment from in the
universe mixtapes or other sources
telling the subtextual story of the
characters the final scene reveals this
song is a metaphor for yondu and Peter
Quill's relationship the dialogue
between the couple and the song I could
have been someone well still could have
anyone you took my dreams from me when I
found you and then I kept him with me
babe I put them with my own I built my
dreams around you such is Peter Quill
and yondu's problem relationship y'all
do kidnap Peter he trafficked a child
he's spared that kid's life by not
delivering him to Ego but still force
that getting into a life of piracy and
abuse yondu took Peter's dreams but put
them with his own and built his dreams
around Peter it's not great but at least
yondu gave everything he had in his life
to Peter to try to make up for what he
did now in these opening minutes we see
a 2d animated version of the eclector
that's the ravager's ship and young
Peter Quill probably shortly after he
was abducted when he's decorating a
Christmas tree with cragland and this
graded floored chamber is actually the
same exact spot on the collector where
the Guardians first came together in the
2014 film the steel crate that craglin
sits on looks a lot like the one that
rocket stands on in that scene now the
credits list stupid buddy Studios for
the 2D animation services in the special
that Seth Green's animation company that
does Robot Chicken this animation
actually looks a bit like the
rotoscoping that we saw in the 1978 boxy
Lord of the Rings so the 1981 heavy
metal but in this case with a much lower
frame rate like it looks like six frames
per second here so this does give off
the 80s Nostalgia that these special
presentations always have really the era
of history that James Gunn clearly loves
the most but with very expressionistic
human characters that really prioritize
the emotion of this moment yondu says
what in the fires of all guards y'all
think you're doing yes ogorith refers to
stakar ogor that Sylvester Stallone's
character from guardians Volume 2 the
overall leader of the ravagers remember
the colors of o'gord is the fireworks
salute that the raptures get in their
funerals initially yandu is denied this
by sakar but eventually reclaims and
earns notice how in that pile our
presence wrapped for cragland and yondu
and others but yondu hates the idea of
Christmas and handouts that may be okay
for you mushy Types on terror but out
here in the cold rigors of space is
what'll get you killed yeah this is the
kind of mushy sentiment that will when
yondu gives Peter his breathing
apparatus in volume 2 expose yondu to
the cold rigors of space that take his
life now Kevin feige mentioned in the
promo that James Gunn pitched this
special while on the set of Guardians
Volume 2 and Gunn went home to ride it
in three days so yondu sacrificing that
film was likely fresh on his mind when
riding this one yondu threatens to make
them clean the latrines but that's
Jeff's favorite job yeah Jeff is the
ravager played by Steve AG guns long
time collaborate in the Guardians movies
and in The Suicide Squad we learned this
is all a story being told by craglin and
that's how yondu ruined Christmas
forever yes framing this opening
animation is cragland's version of How
the Grinch Stole Christmas he says
anyways I just saw on the multi-calendar
that right now on Earth it's almost
Christmas time so the multi calendar is
a new bit of MCU World building likely
explaining how different planets keep
track of years and dates across galaxies
and solar systems since time would be
relative nebula reveals ever since
buying nowhere from The Collector we
don't have time for trivialities like
Chris
this place needs a lot of fixing up
before it's livable yes nowhere the
severed head of the celestial home
of the club the Guardians have bought
nowhere from the collector in the
aftermath of those events which tells us
that Chandler Tavon did survive we did
see his golden blue ship departing in
the beginning of Loki episode 6. it's
not clear yet how the Guardians got the
money to buy nowhere or why they want it
I did speculate that quill might want
this location hoping Gamora will wander
back there maybe Javon is broke and the
guardian's got a good deal and then they
just want control over the celestial
brain matter mining operation but either
way this does set up their home base for
Guardians volume 3 when the Guardians
will meet Aisha's Adam Warlock played by
Will Poulter and have to deal with
Herbert Windham the high evolutionary
played by chocolate you can see the
circular portal to space and the
distance behind them that is Celestial
eye through which you enter this place
and as before this whole mining colony
is a Sandy floor and nearby there's a
neon sign showing an oralone rat those
are the scurrying rodents that are
everywhere and are pitted against each
other in fights in a lot of these
nowhere bars now in this nowhere town
there is a sign written in Cree letters
going down it reads M then I'm not sure
about that one but then T then D and
then in the second column v-s-i-u Drax
says I hate story is where everybody
lives maybe you met a comment on the MCU
as a whole where not enough major
characters die overall but note how in
movies where Drax is there major
character tests are more common rocket
works with Cosmo the space dog to
rebuild some buildings in the movies
Cosmo first appeared in the 2014
Guardians of the Galaxy and the
collector's Vault and was revealed to
have survived its destruction of the
post-credits scene his cccp spacesuit
comes from the fact that he is a Soviet
space dog from the 60s a reference to
the tragic real world Russian space pup
of Laika Cosmo in the comics is
telepathic and telekinetic here the dog
levitates building panels and speaks
through a voice caller like Doug and
Pixar's Up also on one of those
delicious traits in that bag
[Music]
Cosmo's Voice by Maria bakalova and I
just love her little giggle when Cosmo
gets a treat the band The Old 97's
cameos is a group of nowhere musicians
there's these are Mickey Taco lock
that's the lead singer Rhett Miller
there's cortol bokalia that's Murray
Hammond there's Leah vostel Jew that's
Ken Bethea and there's floco Philip
peoples Beezer says everything I know
about Christmas I learned from rocket
who learned from Cosmo who learned from
craglin who learn from you yeah so that
means graglin talked about Christmas
with Cosmo the space dog and the cosmo
the space dog talked about it via his
confusing Russian voice caller to the
trash Panda and the trash Banner total
this to Beezer Purple Monkey Dishwasher
and you can see little evidence of all
those characters and how they look at
the world in these weird lyrics the song
is called I don't know what Christmas is
it's performed here by the Old 97's
lyrics were written by James Gunn
himself Santa is a furry freak with epic
superpowers he flies to every human home
in under 14 hours he's a master burglar
a pro at picking locks if you don't
leave milk and cookies out he will put
dung in your socks quill denies this but
you know there are Christmas tradition
around the world where Santa is more of
a trickster but you can see how a lot of
this is just coming from Rocket's
imagination like he would respect
someone who is a pro at picking locks
and this whole idea of dung in your
socks likely came from coal in your
stocking of course which is hilarious
because rocket might interpret coal to
be a kind of dung that can be used as
fuel because in his mind coal is just a
fossil fuel fossilized remains of the
animals and plants in a way done the
on-screen credits are in a Christmasy
red font looking a lot like the opening
titles of A Christmas Story brood has
now grown up quite a bit from the
scrawny teenager he was when we last saw
him our man's clearly been lifting some
weights you can't help but rock out like
he did when he was dancing to Mr Blue
Sky in the Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 2
opening and I gotta point out the second
verse of the song He's compelled as
creepy elves to do his every wish one
sought to be a dentist now he's sleeping
with the fish Mrs Clash she works the
pole plants her man's demise soon the
elves will all rise up and stab out
Santa's eyes again a very rocket
interpretation of the Santa Legend a
really creepy old man who sees you when
you're sleeping and knows when you're
awake and it makes sense to wonder why
the North Pole is a literal pole in the
Santa mythology also I love the moment
when
[Music]
[Music]
is legitimately stumped by like who did
do that to Rudolph and it makes sense
for Rockets to see a parallel someone
experimented on Rudolph to put a
cybernetic red nose that lights up so
that they can exploit him and use him in
the same way that rocket was torn apart
and experimented on and had pieces
shoved into him rocket the Red Nose
trash Panda and Jack semantis reveals
something big here because of you know
my
the one only you know that you ate the
entire bowl of Zog nuts in the
commissary my
up they're your cool sister I
when that ego did not murder making
mantis Peter Quill's half-sister
Guardians Volume 2 did hint at this
during ego's backstory showing one of
the mates that he hooked up in that big
orgy being the same race as mantis that
must have been mantis's mother mantis
reminds us how ego killed Peter's mother
and Meredith and tried to kill Peter and
because mantis is a group's empath she
talks about Peter's General emotions
he's so sad about Gamora being gone
you'll notice how mantis is off screen
for that line about Gamora obviously
this was shot after in-game came out but
this line might still have been tagged
on later during ADR to reference more
not being with them because really
otherwise Gamora just doesn't come up at
all in the story Drax and mantis decided
to go get Kevin Bacon the star I put
loose whom Peter Quill has brought up
several times in past films and we cut
to Kevin Bacon coming home and taking a
call from Kira voiced by his actual wife
actress Kira Sedgwick Drax and mantis
depart nowhere in their new ship now in
the earlier Guardians movies the ship
was the Milano for Alyssa Milano an
Infinity war and endgame it was the
Benetar for Pat Benatar and now this
special establishes the third ship as
the Bowie craglin prepare the Bowie for
his transport back to Earth obviously
named after David Bowie whose moonage
Daydream was the track that played when
we first arrived to nowhere in the 2014
film they passed through the hexagonal
untn grid and then threw a second jump
that takes them directly to Earth where
they are pointed directly at Southern
California the music here is Christmas
street that was originally the Sanel
sketch you're covered by Julian
Casablancas they fly over the Hollywood
Hills you can see the Hollywood
Reservoir there they freak out the
residents but definitely shouldn't be
that freaked out by seeing an alien
spaceship in the MCU at this point but
it's because Drax forgot to use the
cloaking function this is just like the
tech that was used on the scroll space
station in Captain Marvel Manchester
tracks tour Hollywood Boulevard in front
of the Chinese Theater that's where an
Iron Man 3 an extremist suicide bomber
attack in real life where Jessica
Clemens and I saw Thor love and thunder
like in Hawkeye in Times Square here we
see a mix of Pop Culture impersonators
Zorro Captain Jack Sparrow who is fanny
pack there's a really tall Ant-Man
presumably giant man he's got a backpack
on and a Captain America actor and in
credits this guy's listed as Thomas
McNamara who had a small role in Nathan
Fielder's HBO series the rehearsal I
highly recommend watching them it's
amazing we see a Carol Danvers and a
Natasha Romanov in a go box which really
triggers Drax I'm sorry GoBots kill
cousin so I guess the Tonka counterpart
to Transformers from the 80s exists as a
space entity in the MCU that's fun they
take selfies with some pain tourists
picture with the God of War so this
actress is Michelle Gunn James and
shotgun sister-in-law the kids might
also be part of the family but she
thinks Drax is Kratos from God of War
which given drax's colors in the MCU
it's a fair comparison and now notice
all the movie posters around here are
one starring Kango that's Camille
nanjiani's movie star character from
eternals hexen 3 the hexaner is also
seen behind Santa with the Bell where
apparently kingo's character is battling
demons in this sequel later at night you
can see another billboard for another
Kingo Christmas movie since Kingo was
taken from Earth by airsham at the end
of eternals these might be movies that
he had already shot that were already in
post-production and Studios just now
releasing Drax and mantis take their
money into a nearby bar which you can
see later is named yarvos a nod to James
Gunn's friend director David yorovsky
who me nicknames yarvo based on muslin
Franks behind them this street must be
Cherokee Avenue and this bar is actually
in the place of the real life bar board
nurse where I had my birthday party in
2018 though this bar interior is not
board nurse it's a set it's much bigger
importers isn't the kind of Aria dance
in it's a place where you sit and cry
about how bad your second City show was
ah blue labor board cameos is a
bartender
Javelin and James Gunn's Suicide Squad
in 2021 someone tries to get Drax to
dance dancing is for people who are
pathetic yes calling back tracks his
speech to quill and Guardians Volume 2
about dancers and non-dancers Sarah the
souvenir salesperson is played by Rusty
Schwimmer her map to the Stars takes him
past the homes of Margot Robbie Queen
Latifah John Cena Arnold Schwarzenegger
saved by the Belle era Mark Carl
goslinger and then to Beverly Hills to
Kevin Bacon's house Kevin Bacon watches
the 1964 film Santa Claus Conquers the
Martians and to the left of the TV
there's some stockings have been hung up
with names Travis Kira and Sosi Kevin
Bacon and Kyra sedgwick's kids are named
Travis and Sophie and Sophie bacon
actually just started a horror film
smile earlier this year it's a big year
for the bacons mantis and tracks ring in
and Kevin Bacon's House address is 1988
which is the year Peter Quill got
abducted by the ravagers Kevin stays
remarkably calm when his Vivint Security
camera suddenly shows a close-up of
mantis's massive pupils and maybe it's
just something about Vivint that makes
it so calming and makes you feel secure
boxu is hands down the best Japanese
snack subscription they work with family
businesses all across Japan to deliver a
new theme of authentic treats every
month our first box will be Seasons of
Japan but after that you'll get a new
monthly theme just like this one this
month's theme is Autumn mccoyo which is
the Japanese word for the Autumn Leaves
changing colors I just love that there
is a word for that isn't that beautiful
it comes with this booklet that tells
you all the snacks you're eating where
they come from a little information
about all of them what kind of flavors
you can expect what I'm gonna try is a
matcha butter cookie though you know as
I get older I don't really need the
overwhelmingly sweet flavors it's just
all sugar like a bit of a mix a bit of a
texture right
a shot
oh that's really good oh that's so good
like the flavor of this thing is not
like anything you're gonna find at like
the corner store it's Unique it's matcha
eat and it's just really nice to savor I
could eat a million of these things you
know what the really nice thing about
boxu is that when you really fall in
love with a snack you can stock up on
your favorites through baksu Boutique
both I and the new Rockstar's office
have been receiving these boxes for ages
and we love them plus every time you get
your box to in the mail you can feel
good knowing that you're supporting
family businesses all the way in Japan
so if you want to try some rare Japanese
snacks with us and support the channel
click the link in the description and
use code rockstars15 to get 15 off your
order now when Kevin hangs up on the
Mantis says look what you did and
because this is a Christmas special I am
obligated to connect this to as many
Christmas movies as I can and how can we
not reference Uncle Frank from Home
Alone look what you did you little jerk
Drax tosses mantis over the gate and
then immediately jumps over by himself
clearing it easily meaning he probably
could have just left with her
piggybacking as Kevin Bacon flees around
his home we hear Fountains of wings I
won an alien this Christmas which is
ironic because from Drax and mantis
point of view the alien they want as a
Christmas present is Kevin Bacon mantis
is terrifying as she leaves from surface
like a xenomorph her Warrior snarls are
always so fun like we first saw her
making her angry face in the background
during Infinity War when Peter Quill
told them to put on their mean faces
when they were on the Benetar pretty
much anytime the camera's pointed at
Palm Clementi if she's doing something
Kevin jumps on the balcony under the
hedges lined with these Christmas lights
looking a lot like Clint Barton when he
jumped into the 30 Rock Christmas tree
in Hawkeye the Beverly Hills police
arrived shoot at Drax but the bullets
just tickle him we get the best stunt
action we've ever seen from mantis as
she takes down these cops but then just
puts them to sleep Drax meanwhile flips
the squad car and made his tricks in on
the cops the male cop has extra credit
is Officer R Bobbitt a Naja Russell
Bobbitt longtime Marvel Studios art
Department crew member but he's played
by Barry Curtis head of Marvel Studio
security he Cameo as a security guard in
the parking lot in Captain Marvel this
is the same Barry Mark Ruffalo worried
about when he accidentally spoiled
Infinity War wait till you see this next
one everybody dies
not everybody no damn am I in trouble a
little is Barry gonna be mad at me when
mantis grabs Kevin Bacon's face to
hypnotize them Kevin Bacon makes the
same slack job look that he makes the
Sebastian Shaw when James McAvoy Charles
Xavier raises his body in X-Men first
Class after they raid the Christmas shop
on the trip back notice how Drax now
wears that pizza cat laser eye sweater
but he wears his Guardian badge over the
sweater I love it Kevin says that he
does know Henry Winkler The Fawns
haven't gone to dinner with him once but
they asked him about his experiences in
Footloose when he saved a town through
dancing and when he fought Jason
Voorhees and Friday the 13th and he
references how his character got stabbed
through the neck with an arrow but this
is actually how Peter Quill almost died
in the 2014 film when yondu hovered an
arrow directly over his throat but
learning that he's an actor offends them
deeply he's an actor he's never actually
saved anyone but actors are repugnant I
know
[Music]
did they make me feel gross and creepy
when they pretend to be someone else
remember Drax at mantis are the most
sincere of the Guardians they're devoid
really of any irony or falseness
metaphors are gonna go over his head
nothing goes over my head my reflexes
are too fast
so the idea of someone pretending to be
a character just discuss them on that
physical level and it's hilarious how
they just keep trying with him Kevin
Bacon you have to pretend you're an
actual hero or else Christmas is doomed
well I mean mate I can't wait to storm
them Nazis on the beach what are you
doing I'm a hero ain't I then I'm a
private in the British army during World
War II and then Kevin Bacon references
the Batman hello I'm the Batman
and I mean Hello I'm Bruce Wayne who's
Bruce Wayne yes it is a little weird for
DC to get referenced in Marvel but
eternals already broke that seal with
references to both Batman and Superman
really all the pop culture exists in the
MCU now back on nowhere notice how
Peter's shirt has a little blue alien in
Cree letters written on it the middle
word translates to crunchy with a K to
the left of that smaller is Sassy to the
right sweet and beneath that H it looks
like the word dots so maybe this is a
Cree snack food sassy crunchy sweet dots
I'm only assuming snacks because in
Guardians Volume 2 Peter Quill had that
gray shirt that was in Darian letters
for Gears shift dust cement Stone Ash
atenia Galaxy invention technique being
the name of the prop designer who made
this shirt and when asked about this
Chris Pratt said an interview that the
short logo was like a candy wrapper like
the logo for some alien Reese's Pieces
Peter freaks out when he realizes they
kidnap Kevin Bacon this isn't a
Christmas gift this is this is human
trafficking yes and again Peter hates
this because he was also kidnapped in
traffic from Earth you can't believe
that the same thing happened to his
childhood hero meanwhile Kevin pisses
off a rocket that's a talking raccoon
I'll kill you don't ever follow me yet
again rocket is not a raccoon he hates
being called that we're gonna learn
exactly what rocket is in Guardians
volume 3 most likely one of the animal
hybrid experiments by Herbert Windham
the high evolutionary now as a holiday
special this does in a way parallel the
Star Wars holiday special where the
central premise of that was everyone
trying to give Chewbacca a happy life
day and actually Mark Hamill himself
doesn't uncredit a cameo as a part of
your chugging some liquor the Santa
inflatable deflates and drops onto his
dumb hat graggling gives Kevin Bacon a
pep talk you saved a town for dancing
and once Pete
saved the whole galaxy with dancing for
real you taught him how to be a hero yes
reminding us of Peter saving the Galaxy
by distracting Ronin with a dance off
kragman's right that did all come from
Kevin Bacon meanwhile Kara Sedgwick
calls Kevin how on Earth do you get
recession up here uh a couple of good
satellite dishes out front will get you
anything within about 400 million light
years ah this might explain how Bruce
Banner Hulk was able to talk to Jen
Walters from space and She-Hulk episode
two apparently they've just set up
satellites everywhere so Kevin Bacon
decides to stick around and jam with the
old 97s quill gives Groot an original
Game Boy remember an Infinity War group
played an old school handheld Defenders
game so this is an upgrade also how much
[ __ ] did Peter Quill have in that
backpack when he got abducted meanwhile
nebula gives rocket freaking Bucky's
vibranium arm what we know rocket has
always wanted Bucky's harm ever since
they met Infinity War okay how much
would he have
oh I'll get that off and to be clear
this is not the original Winter Soldier
arm that Bucky lost in Civil War this is
the black vibranium arm that he got in
Infinity war and from what we've seen in
Phase 4 the MCU Bucky has not lost that
the last we saw that arm it was firmly
latched onto his shoulder in the final
scene that the Falcon the Winter Soldier
but we know the dorm Elijah had a
pressure point maneuver to be able to
detach that so nebula must have either
visited Earth recently to steal Bunky's
arm and maybe as someone with the most
cybernetic Parts she just knows how to
detach his stuff or maybe Bucky's been
to space recently and nebula stole it
then my theory I think Bucky and nebular
[ __ ] snatched it then Cosmo gives
craglin a dead orlony with a bow on it
mantis returns Drax inflatable elf but
the best gifts come from Groot who
handmade all of these remember the final
episode of I am proved how crafty
crafty mantis display shows the four of
them on the balcony from the first scene
Peters shows Drax and mantis leaping
over the hedges chasing Kevin meaning
Groot must have made this in the past
few hours after hearing about all this
from the others draxxas shows Drax
flipping the squad car with the two
cop-sized bulging out nebula shows Kevin
coming out of the box again this is all
done in the past few minutes it
crackleds is the most wild it shows him
opening his present in this moment and
if you look at least holding a figurine
of himself that guy's holding the
figurine of himself that guy's holding a
figurine of himself it looks like root
went like five layers deep with this I
don't know how those clumsy fingers were
able to assemble these Miniatures again
he does have like little twigs and Vines
to snake off maybe he used those to
really get in there and as they say
goodbye to Kevin Bacon initially rocket
is not waving Groot has to knock him in
the shoulder to get him to wave and
Kevin says goodbye with hey I'll see you
at Easter oh it could be a throwaway
line but Easter could be a volume 3 clue
because Adam Warlock is kind of like a
space Jesus who's about to emerge from
his cave or his cocoon I guess so who
knows with this line maybe Kevin Bacon
could return in Guardians volume 3.
Peter reveals to mantis that there was
more to yandu's Christmas Story we see
yondu back in that two-day animation
finding the tree trash bin and in there
you can see another present for taser
face remember that's a mutinous ravenger
for volume two yondu unwraps Peter's
gift to him an alien figurine this is
starting yondu's pastime of collecting
trinkets for its dashboard like if all
you do when he sat in the quadrant
cockpit you saw that Jewel frog from the
xandar shop and the troll doll that
Peter trolls him with at the end of the
first film Indiana Returns His favor by
giving Peter his element guns so the
guns that we've seen Peter with
throughout all these movies originally
came from his papa
and mantis finally tells Peter the truth
your father Peter
Peter ego who might be what my father
too which does that make you my sister
[Music]
mantis
that's the greatest Christmas gift I
could ever get yeah I love how mantis
cry is independent of feeling another
person's emotion this is a rare genuine
emotion of her own I have another video
coming out tomorrow that digs deeper
into what the whole genetics history is
with mantis and ego and Peter Quill and
what it tells us about phase five and
Beyond now the song the fairy tale of
New York returns revealed to be the
music on yondu speakers he punches Peter
in the shoulder and Peter punches back
like scut Farkas and Grover till in A
Christmas Story and they blast off and
it looks like Star Wars cyberspace they
leave a trail of fireworks behind
looking like the colors of ogord now a
little post credit scene here
come on
come on
Christmas again
now we gotta have another special yes
group may be a tree but he's not a
Christmas tree and a little VFX detail I
just love that red streamer slides
through the Nook of his arm bark as it
drops like they did a really good job
with the texturing and how each layer
interacts with each other part but I
agree with rocket we need another
special presentation one for Easter or
Valentine's Day Earth Day Fourth of July
or maybe Mother's Day or Father's Day
because we still have a lot of questions
about Meredith quill either way we're
gonna have to move fast because James
Gunn's gonna have to leave Marvel
Studios behind soon to start running the
DC Universe follow me on Tick Tock
Instagram and Twitter boss follow me
Rockstar subscribe to new rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]